everyone is one of the Avengers in game
TV spot for the Super Ball just came out
I paused it haven't seen it yet let's do
this some people move on
[Applause]
[Music]
she'll back oh my gosh that is awesome
wow that was that was all new footage
that that wasn't from the old trailer at
all that was all new I was not expecting
that at all I was expecting mostly the
old teaser trailer with a little bit of
new footage but that was 30 seconds of
new footage now the beginning was just
the city things like that but that was
all noon we saw rocket this time war
machine was tuned up a man was there
suiting up so that actually gave us a
lot Steve said something like normal
people would give up we wouldn't
obviously they're going to try and undo
the snap somehow so it gives us a little
bit more into the plot just the tiny
tiny bit but still just another teaser
trailer but that was awesome I hope you
all enjoyed it I'll do a breakdown on it
in a bit but that was awesome
so until then woof woof
[Music]